[Music]
and welcome back to another episode of
careful boys where hey you know what
we're careful guys hey be careful
that's the careful boys theme song yeah
okay yeah so today we're gonna we're
gonna ask that you move your chair
please into that
position and we're gonna ask this
[ __ ] to sit right there okay
yeah let's go welcome back to carefully
we gotta get this nick today
nick nick is a member of careful boys
and we don't really know who the guy is
we don't know [ __ ] about this guy yeah
because i don't want to tell you guys
[ __ ] he's in your business i watch
watch everything one of the last like
100 episodes he's in and he deflects
everything everything you know it's
funny the only thing we know about him
is he's a [ __ ] target thief
that's the only thing we know oh you
guys are gonna get dude i'm not gonna
tell you anything you have like warrants
i don't know probably warrants
shut the [ __ ] up dude i have spent more
hours with you than like anybody that i
can think of other than these
[ __ ] and i yeah i'm sitting
here and i'm like wait okay i know his
wife's name is tiff yeah i know you guys
get dude you know he sometimes jokes
about being gay well all the time
and sometimes realistically yeah i don't
know that's kind of my thing okay and
then sometimes
oh no that's another gay thing is he's
talking about how he watches the the the
randy jerk off videos dude he only
mentions male porn stars i just like i
just like certain celebrity sex tapes
and they just happen to be like bullseye
from daredevil his arm here
i like that one
do you know what he does for a living i
know this start with that oh yeah yeah
what do you do with for a living well
i'm a personal trainer but now i'm in
like the online fitness space so i work
with clients well only i can help yeah
only fan gay only fans no it says i help
clients that need help with their
nutrition and kind of implementing
fitness since their lifestyle so already
boring dude i'm [ __ ] boring hey but
you're good
you're telling us stuff about you so
we're learning how the [ __ ] do we know
ryan more than you and you spent more
time with us
number one deflector dude that's true
huh you know what the funny thing is he
fit right in right he just kind of he he
he's one of the jk members that just
blended right in no one knew when he
came in and it's the same way if he just
goes right out no one's gonna even know
and that's the way that should be what's
your shoe size i'm a size nine and a
half sometimes a ten so what's wrong
with it yeah sometimes you wake up with
a big digger
you're buying shoes in mexico what the
[ __ ] depending on the brand because
every brand and anthony wouldn't know
because he has his this is true this is
true half size differences on adidas
shoes yes but trucks is like a full size
full size unless you go chuck twos yeah
absolutely what's a chuck two we're not
making this about chucks
if i don't stop you here it will never
stop
because these are actual questions that
we have about chuck taylor that's so
good that was so good
i i just could see where this video was
going because i've been in that one
before here here's welcome to hots uh
nick nick's hot seat we're doing hot
seat with nick yeah what's your question
hey you guys that got deflected on the
history of chuck taylors
you sons of [ __ ] oh man remember we
used to take markers on chucks when we
were in school do you know yeah exactly
no i've been in that video but it ain't
about chucks it's about [ __ ]
nicknames one thing i will say sitting
up here is a very different vibe because
i could see you guys way better and it's
like i don't have to [ __ ] like look
through the cameras
so ryan let's just tell us more about
yours you grow up man i grew up in
pasadena i grew up pasadena boring see
boring they're like born and raised in
pasadena yeah yeah yeah i never met
anyone that was actually born and raised
in pasadena too yeah everyone's moved
there what's it like
uh before compared to it now and what
are some of the biggest changes you saw
in past that's your hosting question
well you know what's crazy it is like
certain i'll tell you about cerritos it
is a trip to see certain neighborhoods
being kind of like i don't say
gentrified but just getting really like
trying to fight yeah china fight or
gentrified it is getting a lot nicer in
certain parts of the pasadena yeah but
everyone thinks pasadena like it is very
nice did you guys have beef san marino
people well because they're like richer
and cooler they wouldn't even mess with
us dude for for a real long time in my
life i just thought it was pasadena was
like above the freeway and up like i
didn't think anything was below the
freeway below the freeway was like the
city side the nicer side the really rich
side because pasadena is actually huge
yeah it goes all the way up to the
mountains and you go all the way up
until la and then all the way up to
what is it arcadia yeah they're so big
they got a south pasadena yeah and
that's completely different that's a
different city it's actually a different
city tell us your true feelings about
the rose parade i don't like it dude i'm
over it
someone that's lived in the past
look have you talked have you done like
a floaty thing i've i've like
watched it in person and it's like it's
a parade dude tell us a personal story
you had with the rose parade oh my god
you were a fighter
you were a fighter you were a fighter
right yeah i was i was what makes a
young man get into fighting well for me
i was very insecure
i was very like i didn't [ __ ] that oh
dude i got my ass kicked like before you
became a fighter you got bullied not
really well i got bullied but like it
was real still what was his name
there was a bunch that was much there
was you're like the nicest fighter i've
met though well i'm not really a fighter
let's be real i'm not really a fighter i
thought but that doesn't make you use me
like a fighter what's the difference
what's the difference between a fighter
and a fodder or fighter's like ron
skull's name dude ron skolzdang is a guy
who fights he fought he had a bunch of
professional fights he fights at a high
level right he that's something he did
for a while i kind of dipped my toes
into it and i realized that this isn't
for me when did you when you get punched
in the face when you're like oh this
ain't for me like my fourth concussion i
was like yeah oh [ __ ] really bro yeah
fourth concussion yeah and then it was
it wasn't like
i had a couple concussions up into that
and i was like i didn't know what they
were really
holy [ __ ] i was like throwing up i was
like dizzy and i was like i just need to
sleep whatever you know so that it was
after a couple fights i've had oh my god
i had one fight where i got i think i
got a concussion i'm pretty sure and
then i had a couple concussions and
training
and then the last one i got where i was
like all right i think this is going to
be it was when i started having more
effects so
like i felt like really delayed i felt
like
i was in a haze
all the time after like for like six
months like i was kind of [ __ ] up six
months
you might have seen
the room felt like it would catch up it
was like a delay
and like i was like sensitive to light
it was just weird and i i was kind of i
couldn't exert too much energy i
couldn't like work out that much and
that's literally when like brain tissue
connecting your brain to like the areas
of your skull gets like damaged or
ripped so that there actually is motion
or like yeah liquid that moves in there
right how do you know you're better now
well i just took a lot of time off from
taking punches at the head and i slowly
healed yeah and after a while like i
felt better and i just kind of focused
on other things and that's how i kind of
got in some more like
fitness and the strength conditioning
side because that's what i kind of
pivoted to as like a career i guess
and um yeah i kind of focus more on that
because i said you know at least
i won't get punched in the [ __ ] head
all the time
you know and i could still be in the
sport where aspirations in high school
like in high school you already knew you
wanted to be a fighter or i didn't know
what the [ __ ] i wanted to do in high
school i was like a hooligan dude i
didn't do what you're just like i'm
gonna just do whatever is fun and take
that and see what happens yeah honestly
that was like kind of mine were you a
bad kid in high school or not i was i
was like a you know i was kind of like a
little slacker i didn't really do much
you know but huh
i thought i was connected with you like
martial arts you were getting bullied
were you getting bullied in high school
no not really well you brought you into
fighting people don't just get into
fighting yeah i love the sport i was
like oh this is dope you watched it and
you i watched it and as i was leaving
high school i i played water polo and i
swam so i was like i got to get my man
car up a little bit higher you know
and i was like and i was like dude
120. i was 120 pounds i was like a very
frail boy i still am and i was like i
should learn how to defend myself that's
what i thought and then i started
watching the sport and i was like you
know what i really like this i got into
it i wanted to be a fighter
and then as i went to through the
process of becoming a fighter i was like
this is great this is really cool and
then the more fights i've had
as an amateur i realized it got less and
less exciting and i didn't really get
excited about it like after a fight i
would just be like uh all right win or
lose you know like i never i didn't feel
the highest highs you know
it's very low level but after i won i
was like uh
i didn't really care that much but when
i started coaching i got way more of a
connection with that and i felt like
okay this is something i really want to
do this is something that i
enjoy helping other people rather than
kind of like because fighting is very
selfish it's a very selfish endeavor and
it takes a lot of
it's like you you you you a little bit
um and i was like i don't really
[Laughter]
was the first martial art you went to
well i did karate when i was a kid but
like when you first were like i'm out of
high school and oh i started doing muay
thai i started how did you know that was
the thing to do well it was just like
i was you know it was funny i was really
into like professional wrestling when i
was in like middle school and i started
watching mma and i realized i was like
oh wrestling is fake as [ __ ] dude i
loved wrestling
i was like oh my god this is not real
fighting it's real blood
yeah it is those are real chairs too
they love to say those are real chairs
going on my [ __ ] he'll tell you that
every time we got it dude we're talking
about how it's all coordinated dude they
go through real tables it's real pain
too though oh for sure definitely but as
long as this season for sure yeah did i
watch the other day
i watched the undertaker documentary
where he's in a crowd chamber and i'm
like dude you're doing fake wrestling
your whole life [ __ ] off yeah
why are you hurt you're you're faking
the paintings he's picking the paint too
advanced method actor dude today's video
is brought to you by blender's eyewear
do you ever do some kind of sports or
activity like me like when i ride a
skateboard or maybe i'm like surfing
like this and then what happens you're
in the water oh no my [ __ ] sunglasses
are completely gone or you might be
skateboarding and just riding and you're
just like oh shoot
i freaking hit a parked car and then
your glasses break and you're like man i
spent a thousand dollars on these things
well fear not blender's eyewear has you
covered so pretty much it started by
this dude named chase fisher who is a
surfer so he knows the sunglass walls he
got tired of losing all these sunglasses
and he goes man wouldn't it be cool if
there was a cool affordable
pair of shades that's also like good for
activity and it like actually works it's
not super duper cheap where it's like it
doesn't even work in the sun but it's
affordable enough just in case if things
go wrong you're like eh it's all good
and his mission was to create these
mid-price sunglasses and i think he
achieved this mission because blender's
eyewear i'm super duper excited for them
to come to my house so i could wear it
and potentially lose them and it's not
just sunglasses they got they got
prescription glasses they got all kinds
of other eyewear it's pretty freaking
amazing and you know snowboard season is
coming up so whether you're a skier or a
snowboarder or a snow sporter they got
goggles so why don't you go ahead and
live life in forward motion with
blenders today so to score 15
off your very own blender's eyewear go
to blenderseyewear.com
and put in promo code off the record vip
that's
blenderseyewear.com for 15 off put in
our promo code off the record vip for 15
off you're gonna go get some right now
it's amazing did you ever uh [ __ ]
someone else up during a fight and like
feel bad no
no not really really because it's like
this guy was trying to beat the [ __ ] at
me too but you never gave anyone like
lasting damage or
well i've hurt like you saw him next
week and they're just like no i don't
i've heard like training partners before
and that does that's never a good
feeling like that oh
that really does because you're in the
same team so yeah like if something
happens whether it's a freak accident or
something that you did that you were
probably because it's like dude at the
end of the day we're
the goal of training
and the sport is to beat the [ __ ] out of
each other you know and it's like i
thought it's to find yourself to deflect
to deflect everything learn how to
deflect what you really feel i'm so
surprised that you didn't learn your new
moves get excited and want to try it
somewhere oh i did man i still do like i
still train outside in the streets yeah
nah i'm too much of a vigilante oh yeah
i should have been yeah i kind of think
you could be here you don't go out at
night and try to like defend the town
pasadena [ __ ] am i bad for not doing
that am i a piece of [ __ ] for my skills
dude you have great power you're the
reason why there's asian hate because
you're not out there [ __ ] people up
and protecting us yeah there's only a
handful of us asians that are fighters
and it's like the ones that we have our
[ __ ] you should just hide the rosary
just pop out
when i see the asian hate stuff go down
i'm like i probably that could have been
me too that could have got [ __ ] up out
of nowhere like you know like no you
have your skills
but if someone comes out of nowhere and
socks you in the face there's nothing
you could do about it yeah you can come
back because you're a fighter yeah
you're like i've gotten concussions
before this is easy but if i'm walking
down the street and i just get
like like cracked in the side of my face
i'm gonna go out also fighters got like
a little bit more spidey sense yeah you
got spidey sense
they see already dude
that's what i don't get about the game
you didn't even see it coming it's like
they don't watch movies the asian hate
fighter people because if you watch a
movie and you see an old asian man
you're like i'm not gonna [ __ ] with this
guy that's true
no matter what he's holding because
he'll take your weapon immediately and
kick your ass and [ __ ] see that's the
scary part that's a really scary part so
it's like if those guys are getting
[ __ ] up then like it could happen to
any of us that's what that that's what
that really means though you know
where'd you meet your wife men are high
school or high school student i [ __ ]
was gonna guess that probably probably
because you said you know
he's playing
she's concussion number two yeah yeah
she was my third concussion
did you sense that about him i was going
to guess it
somewhere oh did you lose your virginity
to her yeah i did that's [ __ ]
beautiful she's my first everything in
that [ __ ] really yeah so you got my
first kiss but oh yeah and you married
you [ __ ] yeah you traditional ass both
of us are we're we're both you guys are
so traditional would you guys lose your
virginity that's [ __ ] cute as [ __ ] i
love the recordings like the super
where'd you guys lose it like who do you
use
a celebrity wise who does she jack off
to celebrity wise she probably flicks
her being into like
brad pitt really
i'll put my name in that i'll put my
name on that list too
i don't know man like people always ask
me like what's your celebrity crush
nobody said crush i mean who do you feel
like you're being what's that yeah your
feelings tuck tuck patrol
ever since stevie came on i'm like
that's all i do no you uh you guys
[ __ ] in an old house that you used to
live in that was your first time that
was that's when you lost your v cards at
her place
was it scary oh yeah your parents were
gone dude did you cry did you guys cry
into each other's eyes and hold each
other were you guys scared though how
old were you were that scary we did it
later in our life like we were like 20
something like 20 years also you guys
were like high school sweethearts good
good kids though oh like we're like 20.
you waited on purpose like kind of it
was just like she's just when she was
ready she was really you guys were
together since high school yeah that's
like
this sounds like my parents era's
generation is like dating you're [ __ ]
boomer yeah old time here dude dude
i always think i always i watched my
sister kiss my brother-in-law and you
were turned on did that make you upset
you got horny
the the bit the bit not withstanding it
was like watching two people kiss for
the first time really yeah i was very
much like let me show you how it's done
full
damn
is it because there's a crowd you think
and they were kind of nervous or or do
you think they were you just haven't
been that affectionate i would assume
that i i never see like a oh that's a
good kiss maybe like a wedding or
anything it is weird when like there's
so many people because everyone's
judging there's maybe an entertaining
one where it's like oh you but it's not
necessarily like whoa this they nobody
exists here right now but they you know
what are those my point is you guys have
only [ __ ] each other so you guys
watching you guys
have sex could be really funny you guys
could basically both suck at this thing
but not know but you're having a blast
that's why i asked her i'm like we
should be able to film this so we could
like study this later
[ __ ] no you could be feeding it
himself that's why when she asks when i
get when i ask for feedback on my
performance
i do
i'm like hey what was that like what's
good like what's
what's my rotten tomatoes on this yeah
yeah so it's usually across the table
when you ask her
yeah like at a desk yeah we sit down i
get a clipboard out
like that that sounds like a bart move
you guys first time doing it
at her house or whatever had you already
dropped the love bomb did you do it
mid-sex or after oh no we were already
saying we loved each other
what was the hesitation about sex until
21 i don't know i think it was just like
time and place because at that time it
was very it was very dependent on like
the the resources you had like where you
could
you know you got a penis she's got a
vagina
did you ever bust nuts on her leg or
anything a bus nuts on her legs like
what do you mean like she's still a
virgin but she was jacking you off like
dry humps and stuff you're like at home
plate but you don't touch it you didn't
try to [ __ ] put your dick in between
her thighs and [ __ ] it yeah what are you
talking about
you weren't [ __ ] her elbow and i
might try it later tonight i'm gonna see
what's up i'm gonna see what wifey says
i'll ask you but we we never did that
kind of [ __ ] it didn't incrementally
lead to like going all the way we were
dry hump kings bro
she was like you guys were jerking each
other off and stuff you're flicking the
bean all that [ __ ] yeah like
but just the actual act is she religious
so she was like she grew up catholic but
she's not really catholic but i feel
like more of a freak the catholic the
catholic guilt was like a thing though
you know i mean i think for me too i i
can relate to that for sure you're
catholic oh yeah
he's just guilt
you grew up catholic yeah yeah yeah oh
sure you
we got three catholics in here i'm not
catholic ah you're vietnamese i thought
you were catholic no no my my parents
actually uh are buddhists we talked
about last time with sound mike we're
the same yeah as christians i went i was
at a lot of vietnamese catholic stuff
because like when your parents don't
want to take care of you and then like
throw you away with their friends and
stuff you have to go to church like i
did that silent mike's catholic so we we
oh that's right
yeah catholic guilt yeah that's real
though like i could see it i could see
it in her sometimes like even today
sometimes when i ask her about like my
performance review after we make love
your feedback yeah feedback sometimes i
i don't really like believe what she
tells me i'm like okay what don't you do
what don't you do well she's just like
yeah it was great it was fun did you not
have fun and i'm like yeah it was great
and then that no the upwards inflection
though that's bad yeah i don't know if
i'm just protecting that just looks
i just always assume i didn't do that
good and i could do it that's why you
got to just sneak a teddy bear camera in
there yeah you know what i mean just
like watch it for yourself because it's
really it's really because you care
about her that yeah
and i always tell her i'm like yo if
people watching us make love i feel like
people would pay for it that's why i
tell her and then she goes yeah or get
paid for it's a new world she's like
what dude but what about children we
think about it we're thinking like maybe
because i'm we just turned 29 both of us
yeah young son of a [ __ ] we're thinking
like maybe like 30 31 32-ish soon man
yeah soon as hell bro because there's
nine months of pregnancy you understand
okay
what if you have a kid and he or she
wants to be a fighter one day i'm gonna
tell her choose something else really
yeah yeah straight up
will you strong-arm it like you're not
doing fighting i'll kick your ass
what if she's [ __ ] here she's [ __ ]
good though no no if if they want to we
have to do it the right way like that's
just the way it is like with anything
right that's cool though if you if you
want to do this that's like [ __ ]
alfred talking to bruce wayne i know
yeah that's way more motivating yeah
would you say that if they want if their
passion was crack we're going to do this
the right way if you're going to smoke
crack you're going to be the best at it
you're going to be the number one crack
smoker so you're going to smoke crack
look you're going to be famous we call
cocaine for the rich people
right yeah that's the right way that is
true i don't know if alfred can help
bruce wayne
like well i want to smoke crack then no
master williams
i have the best coke from colombia
cut with no [ __ ] yeah but no if my
kid wants to be a fighter i would feel
some type of way about it but if they
you know cause there's a lot of
different tests that you have to go
through as far as like your ceiling to
become a fighter like there's a lot of
different things that you have to go
through and i think part of it is like
the direction that you take your athlete
whether in this case
and making sure that you're
giving them the right baseline and the
right like fundamentals to be able to
be a good fighter right at the other day
but it's a tough [ __ ] it's so hard
the gift i would give your kid is i
would show up at like a house party with
a six pack of beer in my arm like this
and i'd be like i've seen a lot of
things in my day
but you ain't never gonna be a [ __ ]
fighter
that's what's unique that's a fire you
need a chip on the shoulder bro they
need that drunk guy to be like steve
doesn't [ __ ] believe in me man oh you
think you could be a fighter huh
and we're all laughing ah this [ __ ]
shrimp
and then we needed a crowd of uncles
saying all that hey nick
just like your daddy
hey nick your kids funny as [ __ ] man
well he'd be a comedian i don't know
about a fighter
i want to hire this guy no i'm just
kidding you can never be a [ __ ]
comedian
and there's a [ __ ]
time warp into like the future he just
saw that moment and he's like [ __ ]
fighting yeah he's in the mirror
fighting and then he goes out and gets
his ass kicked yeah
uncle steve was right [ __ ]
yeah and i'm in the i'm in the
auditorium i'm like i thought it was
[ __ ] good i don't know
the movie they're so supportive though
the most important thing
we're
oh that's gonna be a head injury for
sure
it's his kid who's fighting him
that's why he's there trying to get in
his head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you